Fleet will change or not.
We're not.
That just keeps quashing them,
but I wonder did the problem is I'll way is connected with the communist
government.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
That they're completely integrated.
So it's,
I mean,
the separation of business and government over there is,
it's very sketchy.
Right?
Yeah.
Fuck.
Do I know,
I'm just,
I just wonder if there's a fear of Asian success.
Yeah.
I mean,
how could that be though if the Samsung Samsung has everywhere they're,
they're going to come for everybody.
So they're coming for us right now.
It's only a matter of time.
You know,
who's they?
The people who want equality of outcome for everyone.
Oh,
who are those people?
The people who are really into identity politics,
do you think?
I,
I didn't really think that's what was holding back Walway.
I thought it was the government,
the government was worried about them getting too much money and power.
But I guess if you're asking me in terms of my,
my view on things and in my experience,
that's where I would take it.
So the equality of outcome people,
the reason why they're trying to keep Asians or at least limit the number of
Asians and Co,
but does that have the opposite effect?
Doesn't that make Asians work even harder?
Yeah.
And I mean if you keep them out of Harvard,
they're just going to go to Yale,
go to,
it doesn't have numbers like that.
So at cal tech,
there are a lot of Asians there cause they don't,
uh,
they don't discriminate,
so they just dominate.
So you could use,
caltech is a petri dish.
Yeah.
Hmm.
But what's wrong with that?
It's like it doesn't the nation,
but no,
no,
no.
The other thing,
like what's wrong with certain cultures dominating?
I don't think there's anything wrong with that.
I think,
well,
I mean,
if you're asking me in terms of what people see as a problem,
I think because it looks as though other groups are not getting a fair chance.
It doesn't look,
it makes,
it doesn't make people feel good.
Right.
Because it means that you're acknowledging at some level that some people are
doing better than other people.
And that makes some people uncomfortable.
Right?
It's the participation trophy world.
Yeah.
The equality of outcome world.
That's exactly what it is.
Right?
Right.
But it's gone to a place where it becomes indefensible.
So instead of re trying to raise up people whose scores are lower and give them
any blog,
take people from impoverished areas with poor education and give them more of a
chance,
which is what affirmative action was supposed to be about.
Yeah.
Instead of that,
you're doing it from the top down.
You go and go on,
and I was too many of these people that are doing good.
We've got squash it,
we're going to limit their ability.
But how could they do that in good conscience?
That's what's crazy.
But did doing it from that perspective,
doing it like looking at a race that's super successful,
that is also a minority and saying too of them.
Well,
that's the thing.
I mean,
I think these people do think they're doing something good.
They're doing it for the better of society and for these other groups.
I like to see it too.
Have you ever talked to someone about it that's pro discrimination against
Asians?
I have after I wrote that column for the Globe and Mail,
a number of people came out of the woodwork to tell me how wrong I was.
And there was some white,
some Asians too.
Yeah.
Well to say don't let yourself be used by the far right to justify,
you know,
taking down other groups.
Well that's an interesting way of looking at it.
Yeah.
So that,
I mean that's one way that you could look at it,
but how that way possible to look at it,
that doesn't even make any sense.
You how would the far,
right,
so the far right,
the hold of the superiority of Asians in academics because there are other
racial groups that they don't like or I guess they dislike more than they
dislike Asians.
So they'll use Asians as a way to justify discrimination against those other
groups.
I don't,
I don't really buy that.
But,
um,
that's one argument.
I've heard arguments sucks.
I'd like to sit down with someone with that argument.
That's a stupid argument.
That argument doesn't work.
Yeah.
It doesn't work.
But what I find the most sad is there are Asians who are totally fine and they
say,
I'm willing to give up my spot for someone else,
because I think diversity is important,
and I think that's someone who needs friends.
You need friends so bad,
you're willing to say that,
but that's a virtue signaling thing.
That's one of those,
I hope so.
I hope it's purchasing the lead.
It's not someone who actually thinks that way.
They could actually think that way,
but the people cut their balls off and killed themselves because they thought
the comment was coming in.
The spaceship is behind it.
They thought that too.
People think all kinds of things.
All kinds of things.
Yeah,
and that is one of the main reasons why I wanted to talk to.